السعوديه تستمر فعاليات مهرجان افلام
السعوديه بنسختها التاسعه المقامه في مركز
الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء
يشهد المهرجان تقديم 78 عرضا لافلام
متنوعه ضمن 48 مجموعه عرض واربع مجموعات
للاطفال ويتاح من خلاله ايضا للمره الاولى
مشاهده ثمانيه افلام عبر اجهزه الواقع
الافتراضي المسممه خصيصا
لخلق تجربه سينمائيه مختلفه
الظهران مراسل عربي عبد الرحمن العصيمي
عبد الرحمن حياك الله ما هو العنوان
الابرز لهذا اليوم في مهرجان افلام
السعوديه في اثراء
نعم اليوم جميع الحضور في مهرجان افلام
السعوديه هنا في مركز الملك عبد العزيز
العالمي الثقافي اثراء ينتظرون الفيلم
الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه الذي يرصد حياه
وتفاصيل جديده للاستاذ تركيا رئيس تحرير
صحيفه الرياض سابقا رحمه الله والذي سيكون
ايضا بحضور نخبه من الاعلاميين والصحفيين
وايضا جزء من افراد عائله الاستاذ تركي
السديري طبعا الحديث اكثر خالد عن
المهرجان وعن تفاصيله وعن المبادرات ورش
العمل ايضا ينضم الى الاستاذ احمد الملا
مدير مهرجان افلام السعوديه اهلا بك استاذ
احمد اولا ما هو المختلف في هذه النسخه
التاسعه عن النسخ السابقه شكرا لكم على
الحضور حقيقه دائما تشاركون فرحتنا فرحه
صنا الافلام السعوديه في هذه الدوره وكل
الدورات السابقه ما يختلف حقيقه هو
ان ليس هناك اختلاف هناك
تطور هادئ
متواصل لكن ليس قفزات سريعه هناك
اهتمام بكل ما حققه المهرجان في دوراته
السابقه ويكون هناك تكون اضافات سريعه
الواقع الافتراضي هذه جديده هذه نسخه
ثمانيه افلام تقريبا صحيح هو طبعا ما
يتحقق في اثراء كشريك
لجمعيه السينما في
تنظيم هذا المهرجان ودعم هيئه الافلام ان
هناك في البلازا دائما يعني عروض او يعني
هناك السوليشن ما يسمونه لاشياء
ملموسه ياتي لها الزائر العام ويستطيع ان
يستمتع فيها
في طريقنا للسوق الانتاج
المنتاج هذا العام ايضا هل هناك شيء جديد
اضافه جديده عن العوامل السابقه بالتاكيد
تجربتنا العام الماضي استفدنا منها وكانت
ناجحه بشكل كبير جدا كان هناك 16
بوس للشركات
كان هناك طلب كبير جدا تقريبا اكثر من 100
طلب لشركات فرفعنا عدد البوتات بتصميم
جمالي وابداعي
واصبح هناك عشرين نسعى هذا السوق الانتاج
يخدم اغراض عديده جدا يعني احد منها انه
يكون
والملتقى النهاري لصنع الحركه يعني خليه
نحل وايضا كذلك في المسرح في الخلف هناك
برامج متواصله طوال ايام المهرجان
الثمانيه طيب استاذ احمد انت حدث في
اصدارات جديده هذا العام كتب تتعلق
بالسينما والصناعه ايضا حقيقه منه هي هي
انتباهه منذ الدوره الاولى وبدانا بكتابين
في الدوره الاولى في عام 2008 في هذه
الدوره الان الدوره التاسعه هناك 17 كتاب
تم اصداره والان يتم توزيعه على صنع
الافلام من ترجمات من مختلف اللغات من
الايطاليه والاسبانيه والفرنسيه
والانجليزيه وايضا تاليف عربي وايضا يعني
تاليف سعودي لكتاب سعوديين مهتمين وان
نساعدهم في عمليات توفيق استاذ احمد
مهرجان رائع واستمر عام بعد عام
خالد كما شاهدنا حقيقه يعني قضيه نحل
متنوعه واسماء كبيره من الفنانين
السعوديين وغير السعوديين ايضا ومن جميع
انحاء العالم لحضور هذا المهرجان الذي
يتطور اكثر فاكثر عاما بعد عام شكرا لك
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مركز اثراء في
الظهران